Appena arrivata in questo
studio dentistico a lavorare
si presenta il problema
di  omonimia
Quindi, due Francesca sedute
su due poltrone differenti
Mi chiama il fratello di una delle due
e mi dice
"Di' a mia sorella che mamma ha fatto
un incidente in auto
E sto andando.. e sto venendo io
a prenderla".
Appena esce una delle due
io le dico
"Francesca, guarda,
tua mamma ha fatto un incidente,
non ti preoccupare, ora arriva tuo fratello"
Questa qui scoppia a piangere
e scappa via.
Tempo tre secondi,
esce l'altra Francesca dallo studio.
Mi accorgo che l'informazione
avrei dovuto darla a lei
Giampazzo: "Ragazzi, vi rimbocco i croccantini?"
Ciao Guglielmo,
allora la mia figura di merda
più grossa, insieme
al mio ragazzo
e ad una coppia di nostri amici,
stavamo parlando delle persone
che se la tirano, perchè fanno parte
del mondo dello spettacolo...
E allora io, per portare - diciamo -
un esempio
Ho detto: "Sì, sai,
come quel co***one,
quel fallito co***one
di.. di Luca",
non rendendomi conto che
la persona
che avevo appena menzionato
Era il fratello della ragazza
che era in macchina con noi
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite
vorrei condividere con voi:
ultimo anno di liceo,
ultima interrogazione
di francese,
per l'ammissione all'esame,
Baudelaire,
Les Fleurs du mal.
Ero talmente nervosa
che alla prima ora
un mio amico
mi viene vicino
per darmi il buongiorno
ed io rispondo
ruttando!
Lavinia: "Credo lui abbia equivocato"
Notaio: "Credo tu abbia sbagliato a leggere"
Notaio: "Certo che la può rifare"
Notaio: "La può rifare,
perchè magari la mia calligrafia non è di generale comprensione"
Nel negozio dove lavoro,
il 23 dicembre,
siamo avvolti dal caos
e dalla frenesia generale.
Non contenti,
mettiamo anche da parte articoli
che passeranno a ritirare
i nostri Clienti
Il mio capo,
prima di passarmi l'oggetto
da mettere da parte,
mi guarda e mi fa: "Miagola".
Presa alla sprovvista inizio a miagolare.
Peccato che
non fosse un comando
ma il cognome della signora
che voleva da parte il libro
E lei mi guardava un po' offesa
e un po' sbigottita
Non mi hanno licenziata.
Tutti i mercoledì vedevo
questo vecchietto,
A Via del Corso,
con il suo classico
cappellino in testa
ed il suo classico bastone
di legno intarsiato
solo che sopra a questo bastone
aveva montato una trombetta
da bici
e si divertiva a fare gli agguati
a tutte le coppiette.
Spuntava alle spalle
e gli suonava la trombetta.
Li spaventava
e poi correva via, ridacchiando.
Era meraviglioso.
Sono molto invidiosa
di questo vecchietto
Perchè probabilmente
io non farò mai in tempo
ad andare in pensione
e godermi..."